I assert that if you're not in the
present moment you're running a program
and paying attention is being present
and it's a skill just like anything else
the more you practice it the better you
get at it and you know when someone's
present with you in your life because
they're paying attention to you and you
know when they're not present with you
because they're not paying attention to
you where you place your attention is
where you place your energy so if you
have all of your attention in the
present moment you're conserving a lot
of energy to create with if I'm talking
to you and you're thinking about where
you're gonna go for lunch and who you're
going to go with and how you're going to
get there and I'm talking to you you
left the present moment and your
attention went to some future and your
energy will go down and you won't be
able to comprehend what I said if you
start thinking about what you should
have said at the staff meeting three
days ago and I'm talking to you and your
mind is back in the past you're
siphoning energy out of the present
moment into the past so people are
constantly siphoning their energy into a
familiar past or a predictable future
because that's where their attention is
and the stronger the emotions that we
feel to certain problems and conditions
in our life the more we pay attention to
them so we give our power away so to our
ex we give our power way to that big
problem and that's Creative Energy that
we should be able to use to create a new
future hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from some of the best and
pick up the great secrets from some
great people enjoy
when a person sitting in a meditation
and they're doing absolutely nothing
and it's eight o'clock in the morning
and their body for the last 10 years has
been going in traffic and getting angry
and frustrated in traffic and now
they're sitting in a meditation at eight
o'clock in the morning the body's gonna
say hey you're off schedule I'm used to
suffering and getting angry here so the
body's gonna start looking for that
emotion and it's going to start
influencing the mind and you're going to
start getting images and and memories
just so you could feel that emotion like
now now the person's back in the past
but if they become aware
that they're siphoning energy out of the
present moment into the past and they
settle the body back down into the
present moment that's a victory you and
those victories add up and you're
telling the body in that moment
that it's no longer the mind that you're
the mind and that's a victory and then
people get frustrated and they say I
can't meditate oh really well actually
you're doing it right that's actually
what meditates you're doing exactly what
you're supposed to be doing and all of a
sudden the body says well
it's 8 15 now this is when you normally
you know go get something to eat and you
have your coffee and your body's
starting to want to get up and do
something become aware that your body
wants to get up and move and you're in
the meditation and you tell your body
uh-uh you bring it back to the present
moment and you settle it back down you
are training the animal that's a victory
now you're executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
program now you're telling the body I'll
tell you when we get up not when you
want to get up you're not the mind I'm
the mind and that's a victory now we've
done the research on this
if you keep doing this and you stay with
it
sooner or later the body is going to
surrender to a new mind and when that
happens Sean
there's a liberation of energy the body
is freed
from those habituations and those
emotions the bodies going from particle
to wave from matter to energy and all of
a sudden you're dialing down the anger
you're dialing down the vigilance and
the body now is being conditioned to a
new mind that is the present moment and
when you're in that present moment
something really amazing happens you
forget about you
all of a sudden you're not your face
you're not your culture you're not your
your marital status you're not your diet
you're not your your past you're
basically just an awareness you're in
the unknown and that is the perfect
place to create from so it turns out
that when people do this properly they
heal themselves of anxiety why because
they're no longer obsessing about some
future
when they find the present moment they
heal their from their depression because
they're not a bit hopeless and Powerless
in their past the body's conditioned now
and so then
when they overcome themselves in their
meditation
and they step out into their life they
are more present they can connect they
are more patient they are more loving
because they overcome the animal part of
themselves and the beauty behind that is
is that all of a sudden you're not
predictable all of a sudden something's
different about Sean he's he's not I'm
noticing he's not behaving the same way
you're out of the known right you're in
the unknown and all of a sudden people
is no longer what you're saying to them
is who you are they're just kind of
scratching their head going hey he looks
like he's really happy I want some of
that and now we're out of the
philosophical theoretical realm we're in
the practicum which is where really the
magic happens so the Eternal Present
Moment The Sweet Spot of the generous
present moment is the place we create
from and when we are when we're there we
disconnect from our bodies we become
nobody
we disconnect from people in our lives
we're not thinking about our ex or our
boss we are no one we're not thinking
about our cell phone our computer uh we
are no thing we are not thinking about
where we live where we work where we
sleep we are nowhere and we're not
thinking about the predictable future
and the familiar past we're in no time
and when you're disconnecting or
dissociating from everything known
you're in the unknown and that's where
the magic happens secret number two
believe with Tom bilyeu once you
understand that you can choose to have
faith that things are going to work that
you can believe in something long before
you have the evidence for it and you can
believe in it because you know that's
how the mind works
that we lead with belief that's where
humans generate their power they don't
generate it from seeing some evidence of
something in the world we generate our
power by first believing that our
efforts will be rewarded you have to put
that at the center of your being
and as Wayne Dyer said be miserable or
motivate yourself whatever has to be
done is always your choice
so if you want to do something
recognize there's no obstacle holding
you back other than what you choose to
believe and if you want to be miserable
it's going to be there for you and if
you want to be empowered it's there for
you if you want strength it is there for
you it's a decision it's something that
you decide to believe in that you can
get strong and that ultimately is the
ultimate strength to believe that you
can get better to believe that you can
become whatever you want to become so
choose optimism right now choose to let
it fill you choose to feel it to sit in
that Sensation that anything you set
your mind to is possible when you allow
yourself to embody that to believe it no
matter what anybody tells you no matter
how many people tell you that you're
stupid you're a failure that you're
never going to do anything that you are
going to believe in yourself
if you can do that if you can choose
that optimism
you can go anywhere
because you realize everything you
needed was in you all along
it was simply choosing to believe you
could execute against it
so have that Faith go out and do it
secret number three let go of your ego
with Jay Shetty
he sits down with me and he says I think
you'll be able to share what you've
learned if you leave you'll be able to
share this with everyone if you leave
and I felt like it was this nice way of
saying you're not ready to be a mom but
get out of it that's how it felt it felt
like I'd failed and it felt like he was
like breaking up with me like I I equate
it to a divorce it was almost like him
saying to me it's not you it's me you
know it's not working out like it kind
of felt like that it wasn't disingenuous
on his part it was just it was a reality
check it was a reality check that this
wasn't going to last forever
it was one of the most toughest
humiliating ego bashing crushing things
that happened because here I was
thinking I'm going to be a monk and I'm
going to do this and I've got all these
plans then all of a sudden three years
on all your plans have failed I've got
no money I've rejected all my corporate
job offers and I moved back in my
parents five years ago
25 000 worth of debt so I moved back to
my parents
I'm thinking myself
what do you like now I'm gonna have to
think about paying bills and I'm gonna
have to think about my parents hold my
life so I didn't have anywhere to just I
had their home to hang out in but he
wasn't like oh yeah I'll just live with
my parents for again I'll figure it out
I was just like I literally have nothing
like if I don't figure this out I'll be
sleeping in my bedroom that I grew up in
for the rest of my life and that's it
like that's life sure so so it was tough
it was it was the closest I've ever been
to like a very low point because your
biggest dreams have just crashed and I
know no one can really understand my
dream of becoming a monk but you can
equate it to I don't know playing in
sports like I know for you it's like
that but whatever it is music it was it
was like your biggest dream on the
planet just comes crumbling down
and I felt it it hurt it really hurt and
it hurt the ego because all my friends
or family who are just about convinced I
was becoming a monk when I was coming
back they were all like what I thought
you're gonna be a monk what are you
doing I had that moment where I had to
decide I was like wait a minute I've
been taught how to deal with anxiety
pain pressure and everything is a month
and for the first time in my life I had
to put it into like practice but in like
acceleration mode so I ended up doing
two things when I left one thing was all
my friends who worked now at big
companies they were stressed out and
hating their lives so they started to
invite me to speak at their companies
like Google and Starbucks and they what
else what'd you learn from being a
Monster yeah That's it they were working
on these big Brands they're like Jay
come teach us what you've learned so I
started speaking all these venues and I
loved it and people were getting so much
out of it I was like wow like my monk
experience is really there to help so
many people and because I'm still living
it I can still give it and all of a
sudden all of this environment had a
meaning and purpose again and I started
to see what my teacher had said that
you're you're there to share this with
people also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there secret number four surrender
spiritually with Gabby Bernstein any
desire that we have that we strangle we
will block
you also have a desire that does involve
another person very intimately
and he may not be there with you yet
so this is all the more reason for you
to really settle down and step back and
truly surrender
so
while you may not have had the same
story as me if really struggling to
conceive you're at a place of
struggling to embrace
or welcome
or even agree to it's like a third child
so the steps that I lay out in my Oprah
Super Soul sessions talk
the spiritual steps to surrender
or for anyone that is holding on to a
desire so tightly that they think
they're getting in the way of it
the first step is to take your hands off
the wheel through prayer
so let's do that today right now
the secret to prayer is to forget what
you think you need
when you start to pray for what's of the
highest good rather than
what you think you need
then the universe can take over
you are feeling the presence of a spirit
baby it's not just your longing it's
that baby's longing
to trust that
talk to the baby let the baby show you
signs
be in the inquiry of that relationship
even though it's not in form yet
but most importantly right now being in
the prayer of what is of the highest
good for all for your husband for you
for your children for the baby
because your plan is not a good plan
honey not you everybody our plans are
[ __ ]
the universe has a plan far better than
we do Secret number five control your
thoughts with sad Guru you take away
negative thoughts
don't identify any thought is negative
because it's just a thought
who told you it's negative it's just a
thought you're making it up maybe you
like it
what's the problem
if you understand this is just a thought
it has no power
if you think it's a reality then it
destroys you
it's just a thought isn't it
is it true that you made up the thought
no
ah if you're having doubts about it
because you are not thinking you have a
mental diarrhea happening
it's simply happening
thinking the word thinking means
you're exercising your thought process
consciously isn't it
yes thinking means you are doing
something consciously right now this is
in a state of mental diarrhea it's just
pouring all the time
now what is negative about it what is
positive about it what is negative is
it's happening unconsciously that is
what is negative not the content
you thought about the devil that's
negative you thought about a god that is
positive there's no such thing
it is the most negative thing that's
happening right now is it's happening
unconsciously that is what is negative
about it
and
a whole lot of people have destroyed
themselves trying to stop those thoughts
that they think are negative
and
they try to fight them in so many
different ways you create these things
and then you fight them
[Music]
it's your thought
you must be able to throw it and roll it
back whenever you want isn't it you must
be able to roll it out and roll it in as
you want but right now your own ghosts
have become so big
[Music]
that you want to fight then if you win
you're really lost
because something that is not true if
you fight and win it you have really
lost it isn't it
so there is no such thing as negative
and positive thought
either it's a conscious thought or it's
a diarrhea
so how to stop this see suppose you are
having diarrhea physical diarrhea
first thing to do is
every other treatment is next first
thing to do is stop eating bad food
isn't it
something cause diarrhea first thing you
stop eating bad food whatever cause this
stop that
this is the first thing you must do
right now the bad food is just this you
identified yourself with something that
you are not
now you can't stop your thought process
do what you want you do any Mantra you
won't think of any God you want do
whatever the hell you want the moment
you identify yourself with something
that you are not you cannot stop your
mind and secret number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
forgive with Tony Robbins have you ever
been stuck have there been a place where
you were frustrated or angry or sad or
you're worried you're stressed and you
just couldn't get yourself out of it
usually that happens because there's a
lack of forgiveness what would happen if
you just let go and most of the
challenges we have in our life are
because we have unmet expectations
listen have you ever snapped at somebody
unfairly and so bad about it afterwards
had nothing to do with them it was just
the state of stress you're in it's not
an excuse but you understand well then
have you ever been snapped at I wouldn't
remember that you've been a person who
snapped
and doing the best we can
and yes that sometimes we're resourceful
and things slow and sometimes not so if
you want an extraordinary life you can't
have a life filled with joy and
gratitude and happiness and fulfillment
it's
Esther and Away act a certain way talk a
certain way to meet your needs because
here's the real truth
you'll usually are really not forgiving
yourself because the truth of the matter
is we don't all live the way we think we
should act the way we should work out
the way we should treat our kids every
month if they should you know have the
mental mindset that we should every
moment I know nobody does
so the ability to just let go that's all
forgiveness is is let go let God or let
go and move
on something better give someone
forgiveness give yourself forgiveness
just let it go it's a gift you give you
give self it's this capacity to
understand that resentment just destroys
us the person who hurt me you don't
forgive is you
Mendel himself said resentment is like
drinking poison and then expecting your
enemy to die so could you choose right
now to forgive someone for something
could you just not have to wait for a
perfect apology or perfect conditions or
them to prove themselves
you're just magnanimous what is the
spear the spirit of the holidays is
really about that concept of whatever
religion or whatever belief you have
that concept of just letting go and
loving in spite of whatever Behavior we
have because human beings are not their
behavior and instead of perfection which
no human being is you are forgiving to
yourself to say hey I learned and I grew
and the people around me are learning
and growing
we're all here at Earth's school
together figuring this stuff out so
here's my question what could you let go
of right now and for yourself
what wrong what upset what phrase what
Behavior could you just truly give
yourself the gift to Free Yourself of
and who else could you free would you
set yourself free
and win would now be a good time to do
it if not in the holidays when give
yourself a gift give the gift to someone
today consciously radically forgive
and no you don't have to live in fear
that it's going to happen again we're
all growing we're all expanding and each
day as a new adventure in the exploring
of what it means to be human
holidays are a time to maybe bring in
some of the Dubai
everyone has unresolved areas where they
are out of alignment due to their
upbringing their belief systems from
childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted so some people might be
Health some people might be sex some
people it might be money some people it
might be their worth some people might
be all of the above whatever we've all
got it we've all got an area or many
where we are misaligned with the feeling
of love and abundance and and Grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay so the undoing of
the lack mentality is a journey of
clearing the belief systems from a
experiential time in your life right
that happens once again through books
like the universe has your back so
fantastic that you're doing that
transform fear to Faith excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural Pathways from the
experiences that we've had as children
particularly young childhood experiences
but the good news is thanks to
neuroplasticity our brain actually can
and
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our PTSD can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new Behavior so one thing that you can
do simply In This Moment is to notice
when you are in that lack mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method I've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes I could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy whichever one I hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but what you can do
for yourself you're here for self-help
you're here for Gabby to tell me how I
can serve myself you can be in the
proactive development of new thought
patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack Story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel step two forgive
yourself for having the thought it's
very simple up there is my childhood
story there's my parents lack story
again up there it is again all right I
forgive myself it just showed up again
because that forgiveness will dissolve
that guilt and tension and fear that
you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step choose the next best feeling
thought choose the thought of you know
what I just forgave myself for that
thought so I'm dissolving it in this
moment I actually am listening to the
universe has your back and it's so
supportive then I can actually go and
listen to Super tractor so you can go
from thought to thought to thought to
reach for the next best feeling thought
so your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you right and
especially if you're feeling afraid that
you're manifesting things because you're
having the thoughts then just forgive
the thoughts because or forgive yourself
for having the thought because the
moment that you say oh I forgive myself
for that thought or I forgive that
thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized I am not that
thought it's just a thought that I keep
thinking I am not that belief it's just
a thought that I keep thinking your
brain has evolved to be a thing
and there is a lot rightly so of focus
in the popular Zeitgeist around mindset
about understanding the mind and that is
critically important but so few people
take the time to really understand what
gives birth to the mind which is your
biology and so understanding
your mind
within the context of evolution and the
Brain become critically important and
people that uh don't take the time to
distinguish between the brain and the
mind are doing themselves a disservice I
think much of what they go through is
going to be
it's going to be surprising is what I
was going to say but the reality is what
people end up getting stuck on is they
confuse feeling with thinking and
the immediacy of feelings the visceral
nature of them there's something about
embedded in the way that we experience
an emotion is this just screaming from
our subconscious that this is real this
is true this is this is like this is it
this is the context everything you need
to know dear mind is contained in this
emotion and
it's really an interesting process that
I I think warrants a lot more thought on
certainly my part uh and probably
Sciences part and for sure
um any of you that are following along
at home uh a big part of what you should
be thinking about
is the Nuance of how all of this comes
into being and how
how emotions are
the great trick that they pull is they
they paint themselves to be self-evident
thank you for letting me think in real
time here this is interesting
emotions feel self-evidently
right I don't even want to say true
because true doesn't capture what's
really going on when I try to talk about
the physics of Being Human a big part of
that is that sense
that my reaction
to this moment to this event
does not strike me as a decision it
strikes me as self-evidently right
because of the things that I feel
and
I'm pretty sure that as we went through
one of the classes I read
um a quote by Thomas Soul which I'm
going to paraphrase and it's
the problem isn't that Timmy doesn't
know how to read the problem isn't even
that Timmy doesn't know how to think the
problem is that Timmy doesn't know what
thinking is he confuses it for feeling
and we feel something
It Feels So self-evidently Right that
this reaction that we're having is not
an echo of biology and context and our
own life experiences in a bazillion
decisions about what to believe that we
have made it feels self-evidently the
only
logical way to react to this set of
circumstances and that is what leads
people to spiral because people have
different reactions they both think they
are self-evidently right and people
spiral and so now re-anchoring you guys
back around this idea of no no you have
a goal
the only thing that matters is Will
reacting the way that you're reacting
take you towards that goal and if we can
all Embrace this idea of fulfillment
that fulfillment is the goal having a
positive emotional state that is
resilient to the ups and downs of life
because we have self-respect self-worth
we're elevating ourselves and proving
ourselves and elevating improving those
around us
if that's our goal and we can all buy
into that now we have a steering
mechanism and this is the thing that's
crazy making for me in this you know
um cultural upheaval that we're living
through right now which is people don't
agree on what the goal is and when you
don't agree on what the goal is now you
have what Lisa and I call a collision of
values when you have a collision of
values either talk about the Collision
of values or shut the [ __ ] up like
legitimately those are your two options
because option one
let's talk about the Collision of values
and like what should be the goal
fruitful things can come out of that
arguing about the T as Lisa and I call
it the biggest argument we ever had was
over a cup of tea now you can imagine
that doesn't make any sense how could
you ever get in a fight that large over
a cup of tea the answer is you can't but
you can get in an argument that big
about a collision of values which then
attacks your sense of self identity
there's this incongruous thing where
your reaction feels self-evidently
correct
and yet this person is acting in a crazy
way because the way that I feel that is
self-evidently correct there's no need
to even question it it is obviously
right
now
you get these massive fireworks because
the other person is thinking the exact
same thing
they feel self-evidently correct because
they have all these emotions that are
kicked up by their biology that is
kicked up by millions of years of
evolution misinterpreted through this
lens that we live in called life
in a modern context completely removed
from the evolutionary soup
that our brains marinated in
our brains marinated in as they were
formed
how all of a sudden people cannot allow
themselves to conceive that oh this
emotion was a choice
which I have made somewhere through a
string of the gazillion little moments
that led up to right now in this moment
all of those decisions have formed a set
of values and those values are
essentially invisible to me because I
have mistaken them for truth therefore
my values become water right to the fish
fish is the last one to know what water
is it's just it permeates everything in
their world it just is it's like us and
heir
right that actually had to be discovered
imagine
the
hundreds of thousands of years like
really think about how long where you've
got human level cognition as we think of
it today
and yet there's no concept of
I'm in this thing
it just
you're here
and values become that water
you don't even think about them you
don't think that they govern essentially
every aspect of your life
and yet they do and the failure to
recognize that my values are not
objectively real they are simply choices
that I have made invisibly based on all
these emotions that I've gotten which
were kicked out to me by evolution
I don't understand them I don't
understand what drives them but they
feel self-evidently true therefore I go
with them therefore however I feel I
confuse with thinking and I think I've
thought through the problem I think I
have articulated what my goal is and how
I'm going to get there but the reality
is I've just been feeling this whole
time
and Chaos ensues so I get a call from my
one of my team members and she's like uh
don't go on Facebook I was like what
she's like there's a whole person's
Facebook page and they are railing on
you and they're going off about you and
maybe like 30 people had chimed in being
like Oh you hate Gabby Brizzy thank God
somebody's talking about it she's like
you know going after me yeah and well 30
people is a small number in the grand
scheme of the universe this feels really
overwhelming and and even one person
hating you on the internet can can shake
you to your core so I I just I do what
anyone would do in that moment and I
start to go down that hole of of Shame
and upset and what did I do wrong and
how could I have triggered these people
in this way and what we know what is my
part and just getting so hooked into it
even though you know a lot of what was
being said was being said without put
any information right you know but
regardless I didn't even need to dig
into it to feel the feelings of
discomfort and I was getting really
really hung up about it really hung up
about it and took you know probably it
was about a full day of just like being
down and bummed out and I remember I was
watching television with my husband at
night and I was staring at my phone just
being like did more people weigh in like
what's happening yeah and he looked at
me he's like what is going on what you
can't even be present with me in this
room why are you so stuck in this I was
like it feels so horrible to be you know
pounded on on the internet and I'm so
upset about it and he said listen you've
got it all wrong girl this is what my
husband became a guru and he said you
are focusing all your energy on these 30
people who are hating you but you have
thousands of people on your DM on
Instagram that are trying to send you
love that are asking you questions that
want your support and you don't even
know how to find your DM
you and me were in the same boat for a
long time yeah yeah yeah and he's like
you don't even know how to find it he's
like let me show you how to find your DM
and focus on the people that need you
not on these people that are hating on
you so I spend the next four days just
dming dming DM like I went on my
Instagram I was like yo who wants to DM
and so I'm just like in it and in it and
I'm just feeling so like within 48 hours
I was just like so transformed by just
being in the service of others and
connecting to the people that really
wanted to to hear from me and wanted my
support and what happened that was so so
transformational was I woke up one
morning a few days into this and I woke
up at like 5 a.m and I was I was upset
by the still a little upset the thought
came right back in oh there they are why
are they talking about me of course and
in that moment I was like okay Zach said
get on DM so I get back on my DM and I
start dming and I see this girl and
she's talking to me and she's saying you
know listen I um was sober for two years
I just went out I feel like I'm I want
to commit suicide right now I start
dming with her within the hour I'm on
the phone with her
and that day she made a commitment to go
back to recovery so I have deep
gratitude for those haters because those
haters gave me this beautiful
opportunity to be of service to somebody
and potentially save her life and and
and and also just get over it every one
of us is 100
self-disciplined already to our current
thought patterns emotional patterns and
behavioral patterns which obviously are
responsible for our results so
my question for you today is this
do you have the right disciplines
do you have the right disciplines to set
goals create plans and Achieve them do
you have the right disciplines to prime
your brain with your vision your goals
and your plans for the day every day do
you have the right discipline to review
your day at the end of the day to see
what did you do well what could be
tweaked so that tomorrow is even better
do you take time on Sunday nights for
maybe 30 or 40 minutes to plan your week
so that you're not reacting to stuff but
you're planned you're organized you're
in action that's deliberate versus
reactive that's another discipline
do you take time every month to review
your month do you take time every
quarter to review your quarter do you
take time at the end of each year to
review the whole year and then to plan
your vision for the next year your goals
for the next year now
these little disciplines are what I call
Keystone disciplines or Keystone
behaviors and habits that set you up for
success and so I like to consistently
ask myself do I have the right Keystone
habits the the big things you know that
swing the little hinges That Swing the
big doors so a couple things I can tell
you that really work for me
is taking the time to think to plan to
review my results and in a state of no
blaming myself no shaming myself no
feeling guilty no justifying no wishing
I wish it was different or better or
this or that just in a pure state of
awareness I tweak and adjust and tweak
and adjust and tweak and adjust and
tweak and adjust
and here's what happens what you'll
discover is you're going to be on course
A lot of the time you're going to be off
course some of the time but when you
take the time to recognize if your
thoughts are aligned with your vision
and your goals are your emotions your
your things that cause you to take
action and not align with your vision
and goals are the behaviors that you're
taking aligned with achieving those
goals now
when you're in a constant state of
review tweak adjust behave review tweak
adjust behave that is a self-disciplined
action and habit
that will lead you to achieve every one
of your health wealth relationships
career business charitable every goal
you have
the how to achieve the goal is the
easiest part getting yourself to take
the inspired action because you have a
big reason why you must
is really what you need to work on
because we all are going to have
challenges we're going to have failures
we're going to have days we feel like on
top of the world and other days we feel
like oh man I just don't even feel like
getting out of bed that's okay that's
normal that's called being human
but if you have the self-discipline to
get up and do a little bit to get up and
adjust and tweak then you win the game
more than you lose the game think about
Athletics for just a moment
to make it into the Hall of Fame for
exactly for example in baseball you will
not hit
3 out of ten balls you will not hit him
you will not get on base that means
you're failing so to speak seven out of
ten times but to make it to the hall of
fame the best of the best all you need
to do is hit get on base three times so
a lot of people have a misunderstanding
of success and that is that you succeed
every single minute every single hour
every single day and that's not just not
true right the most successful people in
the world are consistently taking action
making sure that it's the right action
if it's not they adjust so have the
self-discipline to not blame shame
justify or make yourself feel guilty
have the self-discipline to create the
plans take inspired action manage your
thoughts get into the right State the
physiology the feelings that you need in
order to achieve your goals dreams take
inspired action daily and don't focus on
Perfection focus on a little bit of
progress every single day your
personality literally ad is made up of
how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that's what
I understand the maybe the larger the
event in terms of its emotion to the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then teach
a person then how to trade that emotion
for an elevated emotion now trade the
emotion for an elevated emotion right so
you're going to give that up and you're
going to practice feeling gratitude for
as an example yes the person says well I
can't feel gratitude and I say
absolutely you can because you don't
practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened or it's happening
to you so the moment you open your heart
and you feel gratitude well that emotion
then is telling the body that the
experience has already occurred and the
thought then can make it into the body
because it's consistent with the thought
so now you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life you have to be all
in and it's the hardest thing to do
because if it fails then you can feel
like a failure
um you know I think of this idea of
performance necessity two stories kind
of come to mind one is I was working
with an Olympic gold medal is Sprinter
and we're in the tunnel and we're going
out and he's talking about the
competition and we get out to the blocks
and I said uh he was really worried
about the competition I said well how do
you even gauge like who who who's going
to win you know in in his particular
race people are winning but by you know
one one hundredths of a second tenths of
a second I mean these are really close
Sprints and I said well how how do you
know I said who would you even bet on
and he says you know I would bet on the
guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line then says
I gotta do this
for my mom
and I was like oh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is it's necessary for him to win
that race for his mom
I think of you know when I started
my career and I really decided to go all
in with writing and online training this
is like 2000 probably six uh I'd gone
broke completely bankrupt and failed I
left my corporate job I had this cushy
kind of corporate job as a consultant
good job left it to right and I didn't
know how to make it as a writer I want
to do seminars workshops didn't know how
to do that so I was pretty much a hot
mess ran out of money I got nothing in
my name nothing kind of no positive
prospects no one's calling me accept the
guys who want the money
and um
one night I'm writing and the
apartment's so small on the bed I had uh
all you know what my bills my vision
boards all my research all my journals
like the bed was basically the desk the
extended desk and my lady comes in
Denise and she walks past me but she
sees I'm like trying to write so it
doesn't want to disturb me she goes
crawls under
um the covers of the bed
and I'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and I look over
and
I see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know because none of us want to see
our you know
our families suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
I was just like
I gotta figure this out
and I'm telling you I wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day I wrote more than ever that
Bird's life's golden ticket which became
a bestseller and in you know 18 months
later because I was like I'm gonna
figure out this online thing I mean
throughout marketing I'm gonna figure
out how to teach I'm gonna how to train
and get paid for it because I've never
really been paid for those things I said
I'm going to figure out this industry
and I'm gonna make it 18 months later
after her
crawling under the bills I made 4.6
million dollars Jesus online
Total Transformation people like how did
you do it I'm like she gave me and she
was my necessity I was not going to let
my woman be in that situation
um and she believed in me she supported
me she married me and uh you know but
that was she was my drive
and the second part was I went all in
with my identity I said I am going to be
a great writer
and I am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over 2 million people
have taken our online courses video
series now I don't think it would have
happened if I hadn't had the guts and
maybe
the no other choice right right to say
this is who I'm going to be and I'm
going to build into that
and it is necessary for me to become
that person so let's go your challenges
don't only make you stronger they allow
you to serve better I think the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
they put in your way allow you to have a
a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor to build to serve you are
built to serve when you can connect the
challenge that you're going through as
something that's then going to inspire
and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to just being about me getting
stronger I find a lot of times me
getting stronger is not enough it's not
enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
was my first ever tour and then I broke
my neck two-thirds of the way through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this was a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not so I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believe in you not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash
uh we're we're next so we're probably
gonna get some crazy noise we have to
talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time and look
we're next you guys can see this is this
car wash or next depending on how long
that guy ahead of us takes you might you
might see it in this video I dealt with
a lot of those mindset issues those lack
of belief issues those worthiness issues
and I I battled them and I've been
through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did the path can
be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I'd never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run
and I was doing Instagram live at the
Times Like A A light run fast Jog and I
like my toe was hurting so much and I
just kept powering through I didn't
later realize I broke my toe but that's
not really anything major right you know
if somebody's going through something
physical and major it's like you broke
your toe come on it's not a big deal and
so I never felt like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through and I don't feel
right pushing people on things that I
haven't experienced in some form myself
right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I'm having concussion I'm in
more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potentially having spinal surgery which
is crazy scary but also not being able
to think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations
you know the first couple the first
night in the hospital I was you know a
train wreck then I came home and uh to
our Airbnb they let me out of the
hospital and I remember two specific
Moments One
trying to get into the car
so we're at the hospital I get
discharged I'm excited to go home fresh
air oh my gosh it's amazing and I have
this neck brace on I can't move I have
very low flexibility and I'm now the
passenger I'm not allowed to drive
because I can't turn my head so Nina has
to Nina has to drive and I'm in the
parking lot of the hospital
and
I'm trying to get into the passenger
side I'm in the passenger seat right now
in my car I'm trying to get into the
passenger side of the car and I can't
and it hurts too much and I get to the
point where I have one foot in the car
and one foot out of the car
and it's a Suburban so this is giant
step up to get in
and I remember being so
I was in so much pain
that I couldn't go forward into the car
I didn't have the strength and every
time I lift it off it it killed
everything in my body the whole like all
my back up into my neck everything was
in massive pain but I also couldn't get
back down
because that was hurting too much too so
I was in I was stuck in this limbo if I
can't go forward I can't go back
[Music]
Nina's trying to you know push me up to
get me in and then I remember just
crying
I'm in the parking lot of that oh we're
going to the car wash I'm in the parking
lot I'm gonna have to talk louder I'm in
the parking lot
of the hospital and I'm crying
out of frustration and I can't remember
the last time I was that frustrated that
I just broke down and cried and I I
didn't know what to do next everything
hurt I can't move forward I can't move
backwards I'm just overwhelmed by pain
and frustration and I'm crying in the
parking lot of the hospital
eventually Nina
just pushes me in
one hand on each butt cheek and like in
you go and I got it and it hurt but but
then I was in
and that was just
an overwhelming moment
and then I remember that night
here we go car wash
that night
uh it was I mean I can't sleep it's
terrible i've got you know neck brace on
I'm not used to sleeping with it I'm in
massive pain and it's it's three in the
morning
and I have to go to the bathroom
and so I'm sitting I I can get myself to
sit up they taught me in the hospital
how to push yourself from
um
lying down to
to setting up oh look here comes look at
the foam look at that guys how to go
from lying down to sitting up without
hurting yourself too much like
minimizing the pain as much as possible
so they taught me how to do that
so three in the morning I have to go to
the bathroom I get up uh I push myself
into the seating position
I'm starting to feel dizzy I have a
concussion right I'm starting to feel
dizzy I can't see anything because it's
really dark and
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
fall over
how I got the concussion was I fainted I
fainted my head on the wall and then
cracked my my the back of my neck open
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
faint and I might fall over again
and I Nina's asleep next to me
look at this
were you sleeping on the floor Nina's
joining in no you're on the bed
she was afraid she's gonna wake me up I
mean bless Nina's Hearts I mean she had
no sleep during this whole time too
right so she's asleep it's three in the
morning and I and I
I don't want to wake her up
one because I'd feel bad for her because
she hasn't slept at all but also feel I
feel helpless I feel so helpless
that I mean all this pain and I can't
even go I can't even go to the bathroom
by myself like I need help to go to the
bathroom I felt so helpless and I said
it's it's not worth it for me to get up
and and potentially like if I fall
that's that's that's no bueno right I'm
back to the hospital probably if I fall
so I wake up Nina and I mean it may not
seem like a big deal but it it felt like
a big deal like I felt just helpless
and so I had yeah I woke her up she
helped me go to the bathroom and you
know I did my business and went back to
sleep but
those two moments in particular were the
most painful moments of that whole
experience
it's the best uh
and and the thing that got me through it
the thing that gave me the motivation
was that
hopefully somebody else who's going
through some kind of painful moment
right now
we'll be able to resonate with this and
be inspired by this whether it's
actually true or not it was a story that
I was telling myself I told myself
somebody's going to be inspired by this
and I still made videos and my next
round of videos I couldn't do the whole
thing so Nina did some of it I did some
of it
um and I'm sitting there I'm I'm now
overweight because I'm uh you know I
haven't been able to work out
um I've been eaten as clean as I was
normally I got a giant scab if you look
at some of those old videos I have this
huge scab on my forehead again
normally like oh my gosh I got this
giant scab on my you might be worried
about a little pimple look at this giant
scab coming down my forehead it looked
like Harry Potter the thing that gets me
through it is
other people
who have some kind of issue like they're
having a bad hair day or a pimple on
their face might be inspired by this to
go and take action what Nina has a
paintball whatever you want to show
everybody your pimple on your forehead
again whether it's true or not it was a
story that I was telling myself that
somebody else is going to be inspired by
this and it's going to allow them to go
and do their thing
um now fast forward
make the videos we release the videos a
lot of people were inspired by a lot of
people did message me DM me email me
tell me in future interviews you know I
was I was telling myself I couldn't do
this because of X because I had a
headache
and here you are doing your videos with
a concussion
giant Scout on your face neck brace in
massive pain breaking your neck and I
told myself what I have no excuse I'm
gonna go do my thing because Evan did
his thing
but again whether it was true or not
the thing that got me to get through the
challenge in a way that I'm proud of
myself for
was the connection to service
that it's not just here to make me
stronger which it did made me incredibly
like I can't believe I did that that guy
is still in me that I could go and do
that again hopefully they'll break my
neck again but I could do that
It Made Me Stronger but even more
valuable is me feeling like this is
gonna mean something to somebody else so
whatever challenge you're going through
understand that yes you know your
purpose culture and your pain
this will make you a better person
but the thing that will help you get
through it at least to my experience is
connecting to somebody else
that there are tons of people out there
who are also struggling with the same
thing that you are struggling with right
now and when you get through it your
story will be an inspiration for them
your journey through it
will motivate them to have the courage
to show up for their lives as well and
when you can actually connect it to
service I think everything is better you
are built to serve
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome now it's
time to watch the most eye-opening 60
Minutes of your life check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there here's the hard truth about
getting great it takes time and
dedication it takes a willingness to
accept that you're not yet good enough
it takes the ability to stare at the
places